dans l'actualité ce soir la mort de
guillaume depardieu on l'a appris il ya
une heure et demie l'acteur a succombé à
une pneumonie foudroyante
il avait 37 ans la crise financière
nicolas sarkozy annonce 360 milliards
d'euros de garanties pour les banques si
elles y ont recours elles devront verser
des intérêts et prendre des engagements
éthiques
c'est la traduction française du plan
européen adopté hier au même moment
l'allemagne l'italie ou encore l'espagne
ont annoncé des mesures similaires
conséquence immédiate le rebond des
bourses paris s'envole de 11% c'est du
jamais vu
actualité judiciaire l'énigme demeure
quatre ans après le meurtre de géraldine
giraud
sa tante a été innocenté seul le
principal suspect jean pierre très bon
air est renvoyé devant la cour d'assises
mais le mobile reste incertain à
l'étranger la gaffe de john mccain
devant ses supporteurs il promet de
fouetter barack obama lors du prochain
débat aux états unis le fouet reste un
symbole de l' esclavage
enfin la découverte d'un gène de la
calvitie deux équipes scientifiques ont
réalisé des études sur un millier de
personnes c'est une avancée vers un
possible test génétique
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous il était
devenu une figure familière par ses
films bien sûr mais aussi en raison de
sa personnalité à vif
guillaume depardieu le fils de gérard
depardieu est donc mort ce lundi à
l'hôpital de garches près de paris des
suites d'une pneumonie
il n'avait que 37 ans christophe airaud
ok + 2 chant rageur en colère et
désespérés comme son dernier personnage
guillaume depardieu l'été fils de gérard
et d'elizabeth ii pardew guillaume se
devait d'être comédien enfants il
accompagnait son père sur les plateaux
et en 91 c'est tous les matins du monde
d'alain corneau et déjà son père comme
partenaire ce père gérard dont il hérite
du charisme et du talent d'acteur ça
recommence je peux me répond ce père à
qui il reproche aussi l'absence 2001 le
film et le piano mais aime ton père et
guillaume parle de gérard
écoutez j'ai suffisamment pleurait avec
sa j'avais envie de me marrer avec sa
wii est ce que paul dit à leo ou fait à
léo des choses que vous auriez aimé dire
à gérard ont fait rage est rare c'est
une fille du fait d'une autre manière
j'ai fait d'une autre manière comme
personnage mais j'ai fait pire g mais ça
ça vous regarde que moi
sa vie est aussi une chronique
judiciaire 1991 trois ans de prison pour
trafic de drogue alcool violence et 1995
un gramme accident de moto maladies
nosocomiales 2003 la souffrance est
intenable et il décide lui-même
l'amputation les nerfs la fatigue
enfin tous les gens qui qui subissent ce
genre de chose prend vous lui montrez de
guillaume depardieu avait 37 ans déjà
vingt films un comédien grave on y
reviendra à la fin de ce journal avec
tes réactions autres titres de
l'actualité le rebond des bourses
la confiance est elle revenue il est
trop tôt pour le dire mais les places
financières ont salué les annonces
faites un peu partout en europe
hier vous le savez les 15 pays de l'euro
s'était engagé sur des principes communs
et bien aujourd'hui chacun a présenté la
mise en application en france à l'issue
d'un conseil des ministres
extraordinaire nicolas sarkozy annonce
un plan de garantie de 360 milliards
d'euros michaël darmon alain locascio
son dossier sensible au point d'être
porté par son officier de sécurité
une fois dans le hall de l'elysée
christine lagarde prend avec elle les
données qui peuvent sauver les banques
la convocation est exceptionnelle le
gouvernement de françois fillon prend
connaissance de la thérapie de choc
adopté par le sommet de l'eurogroupe
hier la garantie par les états des prêts
entre les banques pour éviter la
paralysie des économies et c'est nicolas
sarkozy lui-même qui révèle le montant
du plan de sauvetage
l'encours total des prêts garantis est
plafonné à 320 milliards d'euros ce
chiffre est un maximum sans doute ne
sera-t-il jamais atteint autre mesure
l'entrée éventuelle dans le capital des
banques à hauteur de 40 milliards
d'euros c'est le retour en force du rôle
de l'état dans les économies de marché
quand la crédibilité des institutions
financières se trouvent à ce point
atteinte quand le désordre sur les
marchés aussi grand camp des sentiments
de panique irrationnelle gagne
les esprits tout le monde se tourne vers
les institutions publiques
une décision qui pèsera sur les dettes
publiques mais pour nicolas sarkozy elle
permet de relancer son thème favori
moraliser le capitalisme
il ne peut pas y avoir de sauvetage sans
sanction des erreurs et sans que l'état
se donne les moyens d'assumer ses
responsabilités ces jours-ci l'elysée
s'est transformée en pc de crise
déplacement et rendez vous reporté
réunion convoquée en dernière minute
cet après midi c'est au tour des chefs
des groupes parlementaires d'être reçu
par le chef de l'état la gauche
va-t-elle voter le plan de sauvetage
une seule question posée avec un bel
ensemble en ce qui me concerne j imagine
pas qu on puisse voter contre ce projet
de sauvetage
prochaine étape après la réponse
européenne convoquer un sommet
international pour tirer les
conséquences de la crise peut-être fin
novembre à new york là où tout a
commencé
voilà ce soir il ya donc deux mesures
principales la première est assez simple
l'état se dit prêt à investir jusqu'à 40
milliards d'euros dans le capital des
banques si elles connaissent une
défaillance et on s'arrête un instant
sur la seconde qui est plus compliqué
la garantie des prêts interbancaires le
montant vous l'avez entendu est
faramineux 320 milliards d'euros mais de
quoi s'agit-il exactement cet argent
sera t'il réellement dépensées qu'est ce
qu'un prêt interbancaire les questions
et les réponses
avec romain messi et nathalie gallet
l'objectif des états européens relancer
la circulation d'argent entre les
banques considérées comme le noeud du
problème depuis plusieurs semaines
pourquoi les banques se prêtent elles de
l'argent
par définition une banque dépensent plus
d'argent qu'elle n'en possède en règle
générale lorsqu'elle distribuer 100
euros en crédit elle doit posséder au
minimum 9 euros de réserve d'argent
alors si elle souhaite doubler les
crédits
elle doit également doubler ses réserves
et cet argent frais elle le trouve en
empruntant aux autres banques ou sur les
marchés financiers le problème
aujourd'hui avec la crise c'est que les
banques ne se prêtent plus rien résultat
moins de crédit pour les entreprises et
les ménages
et peu à peu la paralysie sur les
marchés quelle est la garantie de l'état
pour relancer la circulation d'argent la
france s'engage à garantir les prêts
interbancaires à hauteur de 320
milliards d'euros en clair elle va jouer
le rôle d'une société d'assurances
l'état remboursera les prêts en cas de
défaillance d'une banque
mais si aucune banque n'a besoin l'état
ne remboursera rien c'est pas du tout
évident que l'état est en quelque sorte
à actionner cette garantie est donc le
coût budgétaire de tout ça pour les
états européens
mon avis est premièrement incertain et
peut être relativement faible car en
échange de la garantie de l'état les
banques payeront des intérêts comme on
paie une cotisation d'assurance au final
derrière les milliards d'euros annoncés
l'état pourrait presque gagner de
l'argent voilà pour la france et au même
moment je vous le disais la plupart des
pays européens annonçaient des plans du
même genre le détail avec jérôme hermes
à berlin tout à l'heure c'était à celui
qui montrerait le sourire le plus
éclatant conseil des ministres
exceptionnel pour mesures
exceptionnelles l'état allemand va
injecter 480 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir ses banques
tout le contraire de la solution prônée
par angela merkel depuis le début de la
crise elle voulait du cas par cas
c'est vrai qu'à part hypo real estate
aucune banque allemande ne semblait
fragilisée mais l'ampleur de la
tourmente l'a obligé à changer son fusil
d'épaulé
cela va permettre de redonner de la
confiance la confiance c'est la monnaie
dans laquelle nous serons payés en
espagne même réunion d'urgence du
gouvernement
et ici aussi une enveloppe conséquente
voilà estagnous pour cette année 2008 je
veux dire jusqu'au 31 décembre 2008
nous allons garantir les prêts
interbancaires jusqu'à un maximum de 100
milliards d'euros
au même moment où est notre argent
demande cette centaine d'épargnants
espagnol ruiner alors que leurs banques
viennent d'être renfloué par le plan a
pas terreau la banque d'italie elle
mettra 40 milliards d'euros à
disposition des banques de la péninsule
mais l'italie dépensera autant que
nécessaire assure le ministre des
finances en tout depuis hier les
gouvernements européens ont fini sur la
table 1700 milliards d'euros
la 1700 milliards d'euros qui sont ainsi
donnés en garantie rappelons qu'il
s'agit d'argent virtuel etc en annonçant
cette garantie les états espèrent ne pas
avoir à la faire jouer c'est un élément
important pour comprendre les bourses en
tout cas anti médiatement salué cette
réponse globale
le rebond est spectaculaire julien
duperey guillaume michel enfin la course
des changes va dans le bon sens pour ses
traders la journée placée sous un seul
signe positif tout étant au centre cadre
des nuits et et 6 7% de hausse
ouf c'est un ouf de soulagement espérons
que
un lundi tout aussi exceptionnel que la
semaine dernière fut catastrophique
paris termine à +11 18% la plus forte
hausse de l'histoire du cac 40
en europe le rebond et général londres +
8 26 francfort + 11 4
avec une question ce sursaut sera-t-il
durable
la semaine dernière les 700 milliards du
plan paulson n'avait pas calmé les
bourses
aujourd'hui c'est près de 1500 milliards
qui sont débloqués pour l'europe alors
que le pib est équivalent de celui des
états unis et que la mesure est générale
et où l'ensemble des dépôts a été
garanti on n'a pas sauver une banque et
laisser couler notre banque
donc il y a eu une vision globale dans
ce contexte wall street joue la même
partition hausse à l'ouverture de près
de 5% pour une journée au moins les
annonces politiques auront eu raison de
la panique des marchés financiers voilà
donc ce qu'on pouvait dire sur cette
crise et pendant ce temps-là faire
jérôme kerviel continue le trader
soupçonné d'avoir fait perdre près de
cinq milliards d'euros à la société
générale était confronté aux
commissaires aux comptes de la branche
ses avocats comptent sur ce face à face
pour montrer qu'il n'était qu'un maillon
de la chaîne est en tout cas que la
hiérarchie était au courant ce que
démentent les avocats des intéressés la
procédure se poursuivra le 21 octobre
image signée bruno girodon et puis autre
conséquence de la crise
hier edouard balladur proposait de
reporter la suppression de la publicité
sur france télévisions et bien l'elysée
a écarté cette idée
l'ensemble de la réforme doit être
achevée avant la fin de l'année a fait
savoir nicolas saros
nicolas sarkozy qui a confirmé sa
volonté de ne pas extrader l'ancien
militant d'extrême-gauche marina
petrella et on en sait un peu plus
aujourd'hui sur les circonstances de
cette décision
l'épousé du président de la république
carla bruni et sa soeur valeria bruni
tedeschi sont intervenus directement
auprès de lui en italie en tout cas les
réactions sont très vives
karine comazzi jaune à messina depuis
trois mois dans une chambre de l'hôpital
sainte-anne marina petrella se laisser
mourir pour éviter la prison à vie dans
son pays l'italie mercredi dernier l'ex
terroriste des brigades rouges reçoit
une visite surprise
deux de ses compatriotes les soeurs
bruni carla et valeria lui apprennent en
personne que le président de la
république renonce à l'extrader vers ya
qui a interprété à l'écran le rôle d'une
brigadistes s'est engagé à la ville dans
la défense de petrella j'ai juste essayé
de voile à donner mon avis à un acheteur
qui a donné son avis et son mari et mais
au fond on touche à une décision du
président de la république
version confirmée cet après midi par
nicolas sarkozy c'est mon épouse qui a
été pour une raison très simple c'est
que c'est moi qui lui ai demandé il
existe une clause humanitaire
cette clause humanitaire je les fais
jouer et d'assurer que les italiens ont
fort bien compris sa position mais à
rome
le son de cloche est différent y compris
au gouvernement petrella et terroristes
elle est responsable de la mort de
nombreux innocents et nous voulons
absolument qu'elle rentre en italie et
n'était cette décision nous ramène à
l'époque de la monarchie et le louis xiv
qui faisait ce que bon lui semblait en
france il ya une démocratie qui doit
être respectée car là ne peut influencer
de la sauce son mari et samedi prochains
ce sont les italiens qui vont rendre
visite à nicolas sarkozy l'association
des victimes italiennes a prévu de
manifester sa colère devant l'elysée en
bref les suite de l'annulation de
l'élection municipale à perpignan cinq
personnes ont été placées ce soir en
garde à vue il s'agit des responsables
du bureau de vote où avaient été
constatés la fameuse
fraude à la chaussette il est 20 heures
et 13 minutes à suivre labour john de
john mccain il indique qu'il veut
fouetter barack obama lors du prochain
débat le fouet reste aux états unis un
symbole de l' esclavage l'italie tenté
par la nostalgie du fascisme sportive
supporter hommes politiques les prises
de position sur les aspects positifs de
mussolini s'affiche sans complexe
et puis la découverte d'un gène à
l'origine de la calvitie deux études
scientifiques ont été menées sur un
millier de personnes mais d'abord
l'actualité judiciaire je vous le disais
une grande part du mystère demeure
quatre ans après le meurtre de géraldine
giraud
sa tante a bénéficié d'un non lieu
aujourd'hui seul le principal suspect
jean pierre prévert est donc renvoyé
devant la cour d'assises
mais du coup le mobile du crime reste
incertain dominique verdeilhan thierry
breton
ce jour-là en plaçant marie christine
van kempen en garde à vue la justice
pense élucider le mystère de la mort de
géraldine giraud et de son amie katia
lherbier
leurs corps avaient été retrouvés au
fond d'un puits devant la maison d'un
dénommé jean pierre treiber chez lui
avaient été saisis également les clés et
les cartes bancaires des jeunes filles
chez marie christine van kempen la tante
de géraldine giraud les enquêteurs
avaient retrouvé du chloroforme
identique à celui utilisé pour tuer les
deux victimes mise en examen et écroué
pendant trois mois
elle ne reconnaît qu'une chose être à
l'origine de la rencontre des deux
jeunes filles sans rencontrer ici c'est
très dur
sardines et katia ta quête de trésors de
marie christine van kempen
commanditaires du double crime par dépit
amoureux la justice n'y croit plus d'où
ce non-lieu frappée d'appel par les
parents de géraldine giraud
il est évident qu'aujourd'hui marie
christine van kempen doit venir
s'expliquer en présence de gens tirent
très vert sur un certain nombre de
points puisque des confrontations est
extrêmement bref dans ce dossier et que
ces indices graves et concordants existe
dans quelques mois la chambre de
l'instruction dira si elle confirme la
thèse du crime crapuleux
jean pierre treiber sera alors le seul à
être jugé et à propos de police la
france organisait ces derniers jours une
conférence internationale sur une
nouvelle procédure visant à lutter
contre le grand banditisme
il s'agit de la saisie des avoirs
criminels en clair taper au portefeuille
immeuble propriété voiture de course ou
de luxe l'originalité c'est que les
policiers peuvent désormais récupérer
ses biens
lorsqu'il leur sont utiles un nouveau
service a même été créé pour cela mais
vous allez voir que nos voisins
l'espagne notamment ont une longueur
d'avancé
le trésor des truands enquête audrey
goutard didier d'art en porsche et
lamborghini porsche lamborghini
elles ne sont pas à vendre et l'homme en
uniforme et le nouveau propriétaire jean
coach protection des voitures très
puissant que nous avons confisqué des
narcotrafiquants kanit est autour du
commissaire quiros les bolides les plus
chères au monde une ferrari à 160000
euros
une lamborghini à 215 milles et toutes
ces voitures appartiennent désormais à
la police espagnole est ce que l'on fait
aucun pays n'a les moyens d'acheter des
voitures comme celle ci à sa police nous
profitons de la loi espagnole qui nous
permet de récupérer ces véhicules
gratuitement chez nous projeter après
chaque affaire les policiers font
immédiatement leur marché ces trophées
les enquêteurs les utilise ensuite pour
les surveillances les filatures et bien
sûr les courses-poursuites leurs
problèmes en chine il
on ne peut pas poursuivre un trafiquant
qui conduit une porsche avec une fiat
tipo pour être à la hauteur
il faut disposer des mêmes moyens que
lui
et ce n'est pas tout les policiers
espagnols vol à bord de l'avion d'un
narcotrafiquant colombien et ces bateaux
sont passés des mains de malfaiteurs
ohler et si le propriétaire est
finalement blanchi par la justice
on lui rend son bien ou on le rembourse
la france aussi lutte contre le crime
organisé elle dispose même d'un service
spécialisé
son objectif taper là où ça fait mal au
portefeuille des voyous par exemple pas
question qu'un trafiquant de drogue
profil de son argent en prison pour ne
pas laisser aux criminels alors sur des
prisons ou pendant leur expulsion de la
peine de prison la possibilité de deux
joueurs de leur patrimoine ou voire de
refinancer des trafics à partir de
l'argent qu'ils ont encore à disposition
la loi est claire si le suspect et sa
famille ne peuvent prouver l'origine de
leur fortune ou saisi leurs biens
récemment les enquêteurs ont même
récupéré un imposant château et
confisqué un avion de chasse appartenant
un truand collectionneurs on estime à
230 millions d'euros les biens
confisqués en trois ans ces biens
appartiennent à l'état mais rarement aux
policiers voici l'un des seuls véhicules
attribués aux enquêteurs la mini d'un
proxénète arrêté il ya deux ans on est
bien loin des grosses cylindrées saisis
en espagne du fait que c'est une 3
portes
si on est trois fonctionnaires intérieur
le troisième sorte rapidement et si on
doit bloquer un véhicule lourd avec la
ministre après de cautionnement pourquoi
est-on si loin du compte
apparemment le texte de loi est trop
compliqué trop difficile à appliquer
résultat les voitures s'entassent loin
des policiers en france il ya des
centaines de véhicules qui pourrissent
dans des fourrières qui sont placés sous
séquestre depuis 2005 il ya eu que
quinze véhicules qui ont été attribués
des lourdeurs administratives juste mois
et bloqué lors de cette conférence à
paris seuls policiers militaires et
douaniers ont tenté de trouver de
nouvelles parades contre le crime
organisé un phénomène international qui
pèsent au bas mot 1000 milliards d'euros
par an
l'actualité à l'étranger c'est une gaffe
dont john mccain se seraient bien passés
devant ses supporteurs je vous le disais
le candidat républicain a promis de
fouetter barack obama lors du prochain
débat or le fouet aux états unis reste
pour tout le monde à des symboles de l'
esclavage à washington alain de chalvron
quand on est candidat à la présidence il
faut toujours tourner sept fois sa
langue dans sa bouche
même en petit comité il y a un manque
ablement une caméra qui traîne et cette
petite blague de john mccain était de
nos villes
quand j'aurai bien fouetter le vous
savez bien quoi de barack obama mercredi
frais campagne 24 heures sur 24
le candidat républicain parler de son
prochain débat avec barack obama
mercredi et tout cela serait sans
importance si dans ce pays le souvenir
de l' esclavage n'était si vif une
époque où le fouet et est utilisé plus
souvent qu'à son tour sur le vous savez
bien quoi des esclaves tollé dans la
communauté noire
une des figures des droits civiques john
lewis se fend d'un communiqué accusant
john mccain de jouer avec le feu en
rallumant le facteur racial avec des
propos comme ceux-là ou en exploitant
insidieusement le deuxième prénom de
barack obama le 4 novembre
laissons barack hussein obama se
demander ce qui lui arrive pour faire
passer le message que le candidat
démocrate serait en fait nous musulmans
il était musulman mais il ne l'avouera
jamais
évidemment c'est faux barack obama est
chrétien mais le message est tellement
passé que john mccain est obligé à des
petits fils n'est pas ou n'est pas il
est arabe
il n'est pas non non non mais non mais
non madame non c'est un bon père de
famille et john mccain qui paraît
effrayés par les effets de l'incendié
qu'il a lui même contribué à allumer et
puis on ne sait cette élection suscite
un grand intérêt partout dans le monde
la chaîne cbs a diffusé ce témoignage
d'une religieuse américaine de 106 ans
on va la découvrir retirer dans un
couvent à rome elle fait savoir qu'elle
se déplacera pour aller voter pour la
première fois depuis plus d'un demi
siècle et elle votera pour obama la
dernière fois cet ancien professeur de
musique avait accordé son suffrage aux
républicains eisenhower c'était en 1950
deux on reste en italie avec ce débat
qui agite le pays depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant le fascisme
s'affiche à nouveau et de façon
décomplexée des sportifs de haut niveau
des hommes politiques n'hésitent plus à
vanter les aspects positifs de l'oeuvre
de bus olini dans le même temps des
groupes de supporteurs d'extrême droite
provoque de plus en plus d'incidents
le gouvernement a même décidé de ne plus
distribuer de billets pour les matchs à
l'étranger à rome correspondance
philippe visseyrias jaune à messina des
croix celtiques des bras tendus des
slogans à la gloire de benito mussolini
c'était samedi soir à sofia en bulgarie
encore une fois le football italien se
fait le vecteur involontaire de
l'apologie du fascisme
début septembre c'est christian abbiati
gardien de but du milan ac qui dit
partager certaines valeurs du fascisme
depuis le début de l'année le malaise a
franchi les portes des stades
voyez ces salut fasciste par exemple
devant la mairie de rome en avril
dernier pour fêter l'élection à la tête
de la ville de gianni alemanno ancien
militant d'extrême droite en septembre
c'est ignazio la russa ministre de la
défense italien lui aussi issu de
l'extrême droite qui lors d'une
cérémonie consacrée à la résistance
italienne rend hommage aux soldats
fasciste je ferait du tort à ma
confiance
si je ne rappelais que d'autres
militaires comme ceux de la république
sociale italienne
navettes eux aussi combattu pour
défendre ce qui pour eux est est la
patrie ses soldats les voici à la fin de
la guerre dernier défenseur fanatisés
d'un régime fasciste aux abois coupable
des pires atrocités aux côtés des neiges
mais aujourd'hui la figure de benito
mussolini n'est plus tabou on la trouve
par exemple à rome sur des calendriers à
vendre dans un kiosque à journaux
je me rappelle que quand j'étais jeune
ma mère me lisait beaucoup de bien eu
souligne par exemple tous les travaux
qu'il a fait dans le pays l'
architecture vitrine du régime fasciste
que beaucoup cherchent à réhabiliter
aujourd'hui comme ici dans le quartier
de les hourras rome ou devant le stade
olympique l'on peut encore y voir des
mosaïques à la gloire du duce ou encore
après d'appui aux en romagne ville
natale du dictateur italien où son
caveau familial ne désemplit pas dans
quelques jours à la fin du mois
d'octobre des milliers de nostalgiques
de benito mussolini vont se retrouver
comme chaque année dans sa ville natale
ils sont aujourd'hui de moins en moins
isolés de moins en moins marginalisés
dans la société italienne
en bref un prix nobel d'actualité celui
d'économie il a été décerné tout à
l'heure à l'américain paul krugman
économiste éditorialistes il est réputé
pour ses charges contre l'administration
bush
il a été distingué pour ses travaux sur
le commerce international
à propos d' économie c'est la crise
qu'on évoquait en début de journal a des
conséquences directes en france comme
ailleurs le renchérissement du coût du
crédit et une plus grande prudence des
banques
après des années d'argent facile
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de ménages
sont confrontés au surendettement
on parle de deux millions de personnes
voyez cette enquête signée aurélia
guillemin et nadia ajjan bouziane avec
bruno vignais
ce n'est pas une carte de crédit mais
une carte de retrait la seule à laquelle
lé droit pour l'instant 40 euros son
budget courses pour toute une semaine
pour elle et son fils de 17 ans cette
mère de famille a accepté qu'on la suive
au supermarché mais on ne verra pas son
visage trop honteuse d'être surendettés
et qu'on sache qu'elle doit tout compte
et au centime près de 50
la rieuse pareil que sa très mauvaise
impression d'euros soit 1,5 à 2 520
cible samedi 1 2 3 4 ou pas déjà
j'attaque est passé de 30 euros ou
encore dans son caddie peu de produits
frais de rares légumes et surtout aucun
extra possible l'histoire de linda est
tristement banale séparée de son mari
qui ne verse pas la pension elle s'est
retrouvée seule avec deux grands enfants
le loyer à payer et les crédits du
ménage a assumé avec les mille 53 euros
qu'elle gagne chaque mois elle rembourse
péniblement les dettes
il me reste actuellement à payer pas
loin de 27000 euros c'est énorme pour un
salaire de 1000 euros actuellement
quand je vais aller refaire un dossier
de surendettement ou là je vais demander
à ce qu'on m'efface les aide parce que
honnêtement je pense que l'ag a certain
age
je ne suis pas violent non plus mais je
pense que même si je vivais jusqu'à 80
ans j'aurais pas fini ses crédits chaque
jeudi le tribunal de melun examine des
cas similaires les unes après les autres
des personnes surendettées expliqué au
juge comment ils en sont arrivés là et
des prêts importants dû refaire
l'électricité la cuisine qui
s'effondrait fin c'était effroyable on a
arrêté des emprunts que à ce moment là
à la barre m des jeunes couples à l'aide
des mères célibataires des retraités
tous dans la même galère
il suffit d'une maladie comme on dit à
connais pas le salaire à ce moment là on
avait le crédit de la voiture on a vu
comment dire on avait un enfant qu'il
fallait
manger qu'il fallait à billets est
réalisée chaque mois par an nettement je
pouvais pas quoi alors on a commencé
comme ça petit à petit à petit à petit
et je le fil en aiguille on a repris des
crédits on sait comment ça intéresse je
tribunal peut ordonner l'échelonnement
des dettes mais aussi les annuler et
intégralement à condition que le
débiteur soit de bonne foi est ici
chaque ronger les assurances j'ai changé
plein de choses j'ai arrêté de fumer
aussi donc je sais des économies et puis
en fait bas au niveau du loyer bages
j'essaye de trouver des arrangements
avec eux même si c'est 10 ou 20 euros
les mois où je peux et voilà c'est
souvent des dettes comme ça des dettes
de loyer qu'on les fasse
et effectivement à partir du moment où
les ressources n'augmente pas les
charges sont les mêmes on peut penser
qu'on aura de nouveau des difficultés à
faire face aux charges de la vie
courante
oui ce jour là comme quelques autres
cette femme peut respirer
elle n'a plus de dette mais n'en tire
aucune fierté bien au contraire est une
espèce de monde quelque part c'est une
honte de 2,2 de ne pas avoir pu régler
notre principe même bien sûr en france
environ deux millions de ménages sont
surendettés et la consommation excessive
n'explique pas tout pour certains vivre
simplement
c'est déjà vivre au dessus de ses moyens
les sciences avec la découverte d'un
gène de la calvitie deux équipes de
chercheurs ont réalisé des études sur un
millier de personnes
c'est une avancée vers un possible test
génétique estelle colin guillaume michel
c'est une couronne dont les hommes se
passerait bien nous avons entre 100 et
150 mille cheveux nous en perdons
naturellement en moyenne 60 par jour
au delà c'est le début de la calvitie
dans 80% des cas on sait que l'alopécie
androgénique c'est à dire lié aux
hormones mâles et héréditaire le crâne
se dégarnit toujours de la même manière
en cause jusqu'à présent un gène porté
par le chromosome x
mais deux équipes de chercheurs viennent
de pointer du doigt un deuxième
responsable à gène situé sur le
chromosome 20 c'est un gène de
susceptibilité simplement c'est pas une
cause de la calvitie simplement les gens
qui ont une mutation sur ce gène ont un
petit peu plus de chance de faire une
calvitie un jour la modification de ce
gène multiplie le risque d'être chaud
parce est alors une certitude la
calvitie apparaît lorsque ces deux
jeunes sont modifiés en revanche
l'inconnu c'est comment ces deuxièmes
sont de mèche pour nous faire perdre nos
cheveux et l'enjeu est de taille puisque
cette calvitie concerne 40% des 45 ans
et plus
hommes femmes confondus la santé
l'hypnose fait son chemin au service de
la médecine
il ya quelques années encore elle
faisait sourire où elle faisait bondir
aujourd'hui elle s'impose comme un
recours thérapeutique à part entière et
notamment comme une alternative aux
médicaments contre la douleur
elle est même enseigne et soigné par
l'hypnose c'est le dossier de cette
édition il est signé josé blanc la
pierre et pascal sid et l'état pour
calmer la douleur qui lui paralyse le
dos ce retraité a tout essayé
et puis un jour il a trouvé l'hypno une
technique qu'ils pratiquent désormais
seul l'autohypnose 5 à 10 minutes par
jour parfaitement détendu un peu comme
dans un état second
son cerveau devient plus réceptifs il
lui suggère alors des images uniquement
positives comme des souvenirs d'enfance
au réveil la douleur a diminué
vous vous réveillez
oui enfin j'étais pas dormi complètement
mais on se détend après une séance dont
ceux des branches
un peu comme quand un couple à la radio
on a peur on débranche la radio au début
on dit on n'y croit pas et puis en fin
de compte au bout d'un certain temps ça
fait à soi que oui ça marche
alors c'est le miracle on y croit et
pour preuve une étude récente réalisée
en france sur des patients siouxsie rm
montre que l'hypnose diminue la douleur
de 50%
vous voyez la zone d'activation sans
épines aux uns ici vous voyez la même
zone pendant une séance d'hypnose et
donc on a la preuve maintenant un
quelques noms agissent sur les centres
les centres de la douleur reconnu
l'hypnose est désormais enseigné à la
fac de médecine du kremlin bicêtre
travaille à l'institut gustave roussy
une formation d'un an pour des
généralistes anesthésistes ou dentistes
des professionnels qui viennent chercher
dans l'hypnose une alternative aux
antidouleurs jeter copier tout j'étais
un peu en miroir je me suis remise avec
toi tu ta des parents du conditions je
suis effrayé de voir comment on prend en
charge les douleurs à l'heure actuelle
c'est effrayant c'est se poudrer des
morphiniques se foutrait des
antiépileptiques se voudrait des
antidépresseurs et jamais réinitié chez
la personne leurs propres armes
thérapeutique et malgré les apparences
il ne peut y avoir manipulation
d'après le médecin formateur
si jamais on disait au feu en ce moment
tout le monde partir et celui qui partit
réel de façon la plus adaptée qui
sautent hors essai ces tables avec
efficacité bien c'est lui alors qu'on
pourrait croire qu'il est endormi il
n'est pas en forme il est dans un état
dit perry veille qu'on appelle corticale
cortex l'hypnose fait son chemin jusque
dans les maternités comme ici avec sept
sages femmes formées spécialement claire
doit accoucher dans quelques heures
elle lui propose une séance pour la
préparer souvenir très bien voilà
quelque chose
il a été démontré qu'elle a un effet
positif en fait pour la durée du travail
donc du travail de l'accouchement
notamment celle f1 pour qui c'est le
premier enfant comme votre dans votre
cas que ça joue aussi sur le confort la
patiente ya moins d'inconfort ça a été
démontré qu'il ya un recours moins
fréquents la péridurale et que aussi
pendant le travail et il y a moins
d'utilisation de produits médicamenteux
mais s'adresser à l'inconscient peut
comporter des risques en particulier
auprès des personnes fragiles l'hypnose
on sait que c'est potentiellement
dangereux parce que ça peut réveiller et
des problèmes psychologiques enfouis et
que qu'on va faire remonter qu'il va
falloir gérer derrière
quant à l'hypnose qui se donnent en
spectacle rien à voir avec la santé
celle ci n'a qu'une vertu divertir
un mot de l'actualité sportive avec du
cyclisme en bref et un nouveau cas de
dopage sur le tour de france
encore un le coureur autrichien bernhard
kohl a été contrôlé positif à l epo
troisième génération cole arrivé
troisième du tour a également terminé
meilleur grimpeur de la grande boucle il
risque une suspension de deux ans avant
de refermer ce journal je vous en
rappelle deux des principaux titres la
crise financière nicolas sarkozy annonce
360 milliards d'euros de garanties pour
les banques au même moment l'allemagne
l'italie ou encore l'espagne ont annoncé
des mesures similaires conséquence
immédiate le rebond des bourses
paris s'envole de 11% c'est du jamais vu
et puis la mort de guillaume depardieu
on l'a appris il ya une heure et demie
deux heures maintenant l'acteur a
succombé à une pneumonie foudroyante il
avait 37 ans je vous propose d'écouter
3 réactions recueillies il ya quelques
instants par nabila taboury hôpital
raymond poincaré à garches c'est ici que
guillaume depardieu est décédé cet après
midi d'une pneumonie foudroyante à 37
ans il laisse l'image d'un acteur
talentueux et torturé ses amis parlent
d'un jeune homme hyper sensible les mots
me manquent pas ce que vraiment voilà
c'est une perte terrible
à mon avis pour le cinéma pour le
théâtre pour la musique pour tout ça
mais c'est humainement aussi c'est
terrible c'est c'est quelqu'un de ces
quelques un magnifique yacht depardieu
c'est pas que l'image qu'on peut en
avoir de façon caricaturale dans les
médias l'image du gars qui est dans les
faits divers c'est sur tout autre chose
guillaume depardieu c'est quelqu'un
d'attentif d'attentionné de police de
généreux alors oui la brûler la vie par
les deux bouts mais ça serait dommage
qu'on regarde cette image là de cette
image là de louis xiii avis je
considérais comme un membre de ma
famille est quelqu'un d'absolument
magnifique s'il avait avait la veille
d'une magnificence en lui et de l'aven à
une bêta une lumière un temps accompagné
de 2 du nombre très forte elle a vécu à
fond elle a vécu à fond s'agit c'était
un immense poète
les gens ne savent pas mais ça dignement
ce poète il a écrit des choses
absolument incroyable
et un arc system un véritable artiste
charabot avant son admission à l'hôpital
guillaume depardieu tournée en roumanie
il a été rapatrié d'urgence en france
dimanche et puis réaction de la ministre
la culture christine albanel à l'instant
elle évoque une personnalité riche et
complexe qui a beaucoup donné à sa
passion pour le cinéma
fin de citation c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo tania young
20h50 cold case affaires classées à
23h15 ne manquez pas le retour d'un oeil
sur la planète avec etienne leenhardt
la france at-elle encore les moyens de
ses ambitions à demain
de l'info en continu c'est aussi sur
france 2 point fr